ma se voi mi senti con il fighter
[Musica]
per ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e dolcissimi nuovo
quanto è bello ogni ogni volta che torno
a fare mi sento di boston natale da
questa prima vabbè che scarta i pacchi
quindi più o meno siamo le uniche
ragazzi prima di cominciare iniziare con
la fan arte della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da non mi
ricordo chi l'ha fatta convinto si batte
ragazzino nomi sono scritto 9 quindi
pazienza che comunque è bella ma c'è
scritto il nome cosa c'è scritto nei m
questa questa è una è una m questo punto
appunto quando sono tornato dall'america
variamente la settimana scorsa la prima
cosa che ho letto è favi continua
allievi selection porca [ __ ] che non so
come spiegare non è che sto scappando
dall'immigration perché mi fa paura
o forse si sono cancellate cancellati
non ci sono più i dati di gioco che i
demo rischiari carmelo da zero devo
rifarlo da zero appunto dove ero
arrivato e poi lo continuo c'è una cosa
che ci metto degli anni ma prima o poi
lo continuano non travasate il tè detto
questo ragazzi posso passare allo scarto
dei pacchi
ancora non ho capito perché faccio così
perché indico i pochi che stanno
nell'altra stanza però voi non li vedete
quindi che cazzo sto facendo non lo so
me lo dovrò pagare stop o dice allora
ragazzi facciamo un giochino semplice
semplice proprio allora pensate che sia
al massimo
pensate che sia al massimo
pensate che sia al mare fatemi capire
cos'è ecco non ci sta nella [ __ ]
inquadratura cioè io starò va ragazzi la
aprirei per ultimo ma giusto perché
probabilmente c'è un altro mondo là
dentro
partiamo dal più piccolo che tanto
piccolo non è ma tanto poi quello dopo
ancora più grosso
sì sì no perché io ragazzi dovete capire
che i patti li apro con questo sì
funziona pure cenere dei parchi a
trovare ragazzi perché c'è un [ __ ]
creeper nel mio nel mio pacco a parte
sta cosa divertente perché mi avete
visto un cric ma vi ringrazio il gol
ragazzi pericoli per lo faccio quasi non
esplode entro la fine del video ci
riusciamo
quindi passiamo al prossimo panini
allora adesso mi spiegate cosa c'è qua
dentro ci servono attrezzi professionali
per la prima e sto colosso per far
ridere stiramenti su questo per aprire
qualsiasi cosa
scherzavo vai così e chi è che ti la
ragazza l'ho fatta dopo due anni cosa
sta roba che le sarà sapere che ci sono
tre pacchi qua dentro non 13 secondo
bear bello se condo fucks una cartina
ragazzi la carta igienica trilli trilli
e il grande salvataggio e grazie li
guardandosi intorno stupita si domandò
dove sono gli altri
terence sorride il campo non è qui fuori
spiega voi lo condusse vicino a una
grande quercia e e poi diventa un porno
quindi film finisco per la vj winx club
rock stars grazie che sexy come ho
trovato ben tre parchi dentro il parco
tra l'altro una la mia faccia questo qua
fatemi aprile prima che oggi è ok ok tu
hai capito hai capito tutto dalla vita
le ghirlande le indosso proprio con con
orgoglio quando vado fuori grazie a un
cuscinetto per le scoregge scusatemi
ragazzi se l'avessi in avanti l'audio si
sposa leggermente mi si è staccato un
pochettino il microfono quindi offro
ancora andato a votare
però si capisce lo stesso scusatemi
questa roba continuiamo dei baffi
bello questo grazie ma non vi se non vi
sembra un gran figo così è un casino ci
potrei benissimo avanti la di in giro
coi baffi basta se non troppo figo non
certo io dopo vado da mia madre è così
voglio vedere che cazzo dice infine
ragazzi abbiamo questo pacco bellissimo
cos'è sta roba da una figlia che figo
c'è una lavagna c'era scritto per farvi
j però se un po cancellato forza ragazzi
alla cosa più bella della vita propria
[Musica]
io
che schifo mandato un baffin bocca bene
beh bello grazie per questo regalo
bellino io per me natale è già a posto è
visto così di questo cazzo di capello ma
non c'è chi c'era l'altro mi piace cose
norme un attimo avete voglia di
spiegarmi che cazzo è sta roba no perché
non riesco a capirlo neanch'io
cos'è è un pezzo di polistirolo sfogati
con cui c'è scritto sfogati con questo è
mi avete mandato un pacco norme per
questa cosa posso sfogarmi c subito tipo
mentre ha scritto sfogati quindi do
families bomber la prima domanda
il ragazzo si baffi non ce la faccio a
fare il serio la prima della mi chiede
fa risponde ma tu hai fatto gli esami di
maturità e tutto va bene ma non l'hai
detto una cosa hai passato gli esami
amico mio
chi pare che un tizio così possa non
passare gli esami di maturità c'è
guardami qualità cenno in continui dei
volumi fino al yen isole show ti faccio
del male fisico proprio ma malefico col
ciuffo è tutto fa qinghai altre 42 la
pizzeria pv posso morire felice
ragazzi questo mi ha detto di guardare
severo nel blog precedente a 442 cee la
tizia di f.liszt
lorenzo drera fuori risponde 6am inoltre
tutti i nutrienti sinatra
cioè io condivido anche il mio nome con
queste persone
rendiamoci conto io cambio mi chiamo
genoveffo da domani gesù santo prima di
concludere ieri fare affari domanda
perché giusta venne che posso io averame
il video di happy days lo farò così giù
convinto al 200 per ci scommettete prima
di concludere e passa la fa mi domanda e
la fai domanda di oggi e se potesse
avere dei baffi anche le donne quali tra
questi scegliere
scrivetelo nei commenti perché sono
quello che è votato di più lo metto in
un video a caso no veramente
tra queste i capelli che metto di solito
non so qual è il più ridicolo però è
fanta sto cazzo di ciuffo lo ammazzo i
ragazzi servito è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e al carani l'ho
trovata descrizione soluzione vorresti
di scheletri ci mettiamo un prossimo
vinto dalle ragazze